the use of this absolutely you're at a
concert at a festival so you can just
piss on the ground while you're
listening with my go fighter have you
ever like peed in public yeah my 21st
birthday I was arrested for being drunk
and peeing in a church parking lot I've
never been caught in public because I'm
super discreet there is a back alleyway
that you kind of got to go in we're
gonna be peeing on camera a pee on
camera if you want me to it is a pee
condom these haven't been used right
this looks painful like you gotta like
snap this on is this so like you and
your lover competing if you don't know
what a penis looks like pause the video
and google it now look if you just put
the tip of a wiener you're gonna get
some spillage the other end like I don't
want like go full dong and because that
user is responsible for knowing and
obeying all federal state and municipal
laws and the use of this product then
there's just like pee like spitting up
against your leg all day even if it's in
the rubber part this could also be a
good exercise band actually no stick a
balloon on your junk and just pee in
that a pipi pop oh God flour on it so
you know it's for a girl triangle oh
that is very elastic that ain't staying
on
yeah so is this just like the female
equivalent of having a penis then you
just have like this wet thing that you
have to clean off I'd rather just wait
it's like to have a dick but I'm there's
still pee on you if you got to go to the
club with this on like you need to see
somebody you're drinking too much
I've gotta go poncho there's a v-neck or
fashion the urine will instantly
transform into gel what how do you feel
it though it says feel there's no seal
[Laughter]
[Music]
and to moist cloth what I just love that
people think that there's a big enough
market for these products this seems the
most efficient like this is usable you
could be completely naked under this I'm
kind of here for this one Oh Lord no you
haven't actually seen that their
internet this is like very popular yeah
kind of aesthetically pleasing yeah and
it looks like it'd be comfortable too my
phone is in one pocket my ID and my
credit card are in the other pocket
where's this gonna go this looks like an
accident waiting to happen
he's gonna splash on you so I feel like
you're making a bigger mess by paying
into this thing I'm trying to figure out
where it's it I don't know the go-girl
could actually be good for road trips
because like guys like we can just like
open the car door and just like stand
and look if the girls like you got to
look for like a field with bushes or
something like yeah you gotta like leave
your car unattended on the side of the
road
the euro club it's a golf club why is my
hand wet someone else put their junk in
here wait like this oh the other way do
you just walk around with this clip
there so and then you clip it it doesn't
come out it just stays in here this is a
very involved way to pee like I'll have
I would have already peed on yeah see
that just looks like a perverted caddy
it's like it's like I'm golfing and I'm
getting really stressed out like I like
it because it's clever how do you clean
this [ __ ] it's probably dishwasher safe
does that make sense this makes that
there is no day that my ding-ding
wherever go inside this your conclusion
I applaud them for their effort I'm not
gonna turn down inventors I just
the ideas are weird man I would never
use them never even the PV pop vastly
not the people thought the gobo that
will actually would be kind of fun you
could like raw on snow or like but yeah
I've never been able to do that I bought
Amazon for offering opportunity take
Spain to preach the P process for this I
think that's an important thing I say go
girl go P and over